delegates arriving at conference on
Monday were greeted with the theme tuned
to a slapstick TV comedy blaring from a
protester's PA system
[Music]
is not for turning
because just 24 hours after prime
minister Liz truss had said she was
absolutely committed to abolishing the
top tax rate paid by Britain's richest
trusses Chancellor was announcing a
screeching U-turn the tax on top earners
will stay
I know the plan put forward only 10
years days ago has caused a little
turbulence I get it I get it
uh we are listening and have listened
and now I want to focus on delivering
the major parts of our growth package
this conference could scarcely have gone
any worse for Liz trust so far the
agenda derailed by a combination of tone
deaf policy and a lack of support on her
own parliamentary MPS this combative
speech by the chancellor quasi-quarting
a clear attempt to put the party now on
the front foot instead
Mr Gove Al Jazeera are you happy oh
sorry outcome but scrapping the top tax
rate was only part of a bigger package
which continues to divide the party
former Minister Michael Gove has
criticized it as unconservative and
other Rebels have joined him the
opposition labor party is crowing their
instincts were to cut taxes for the
wealthiest and Society paid for by
borrowing which in the end current and
future taxpayers will have to pay for it
was obvious they weren't going to get
this through the House of Commons they
were forced into this screeching U-turn
policy experts have expressed surprise
that the government could have been so
out of touch with public sentiment going
forward there are some difficult
decisions to be made around public
spending around Public Services if they
again choose to ignore their job as
representatives of people they will hit
bigger hurdles
this has been a deeply uncomfortable
conference for the UK's ruling
conservatives raising questions about
the new prime minister's Authority and
the new Chancellor's credibility quateng
has had his chance to reiterate the case
for his growth plan all eyes now turn to
the prime minister's speech on Wednesday
Paul Brennan Al Jazeera Birmingham